welcome back to las vegas now are you
planning on buying or selling a home in
2022 we have harvey blankfeld of las
vegas real estate now the sponsors of
this segment to tell us you know his
expert predictions
on the market next year yeah i'm trying
to see what's going to be happening in
2022 it's a risky venture to try to
predict but right what we're hearing
about right now is that while in 2021
we've had about 20 appreciation here in
las vegas next year we'll continue to
see houses go up okay uh however not at
the same rate maybe around half 10 to 15
percent is what we're hearing and this
is based on economist projections where
it's not just realtors saying that right
right so okay let's take it back to this
year right you know what was kind of the
peak in the valley of this of the
housing market this year and then let's
compare it to what you think about next
year okay so yeah so back in the spring
we were experiencing a tremendous
shortage of homes right now it's still a
shortage but not as bad okay we started
off with a crazy strong seller's market
and we've kind of come off of that a
little bit still very much a seller's
market but it's moving a little bit more
towards neutral and depends on your
price range in your area of course okay
and i know that a lot of people will be
asking will houses continue will the
price continue to go up yeah and that's
what we're thinking is that we're again
all the predictions are that demand is
high supply is still low interest rates
are good okay um and they predict next
year interest rates will go up but only
slightly okay so we're thinking it's
going to be very similar this year maybe
not as heated a market but still very
similar to this year okay and let's talk
about you know the buyers versus the
sellers a little advice for each of them
okay so if you're a seller pay attention
to what's happening in the market it's
going up but not at the same rate so
don't price your house so far beyond a
reasonable number keep it close remember
that in the past years and years ago
when i first started doing real estate
you could price your home here buyers
would come in here and you could land
somewhere in the middle but because of
the way the internet has exposed
everything you've got to be really close
to where you're prepared to land you
can't be so far away because
buyers won't even see it wow that's a
really good that's a good tip i hope you
guys are taking notes okay
and you know of course you're getting
the question will there be a crash yes
this is what everyone on everyone's mind
and you hear some realtors predicting
that which is kind of disturbing
i don't see it the metrics aren't there
for that you know back in the mid 2000s
a lot of people bought homes just by
signing a piece of paper nobody was
vetted nobody cared when they could
afford it
now if you bought a home in the last 12
15 years you know that the mortgages
that you've gotten you've been
thoroughly vetted they made sure you
could afford it okay and you know
obviously you have a radio show that
continues to educate the community on
this so how can people tune in and
listen to you guys yeah tune in to katie
kdwn every saturday we've been doing
it'll be eight years in march
and it's a lot of fun for me something
that i can expose what's happening
really happening in real estate because
in real time in real time what's
happening right now that's why we titled
las vegas real estate now because this
is what's happening now not what we were
thinking about six months ago where we
might be catching up okay well if you're
headed into the new year in one of your
resolution or one of your goals is a
home
call harvey okay so thank you to las
vegas real estate now for sponsoring
this segment call 702-203-1165
or visit lvrealestateradio.com